PAUL KINLAN: Hello, and welcome
to another Chrome
Mobile Thursday.
SAM DUTTON: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, I got that
wrong in an earlier take.
Anyway, this episode
is about media.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
I'm with Sam Dutton, developer
advocate from Google Chrome.
And today's about
media mobile.
Media's an area--
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, absolutely.
PAUL KINLAN: It's an area
that you specialize in.
In particular, it's about
media on mobile as well.
So a lot of people think of
video and everything--
everything to do with video
is mainly desktop-based.
A lot of people think
that you can only
play videos on desktops.
Obviously, that's not true.
We can do it on mobiles.
But we've got a nice
[INAUDIBLE]
new things coming inside
Chrome for Cran--
Chrome for Crandroid?--
Chrome for Android, at least.
SAM DUTTON: Crandoid
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL KINLAN: getUserMedia's a
big one, so I've been able to
actually get access
to the webcam.
There's a thing called
getUserMedia with Constraints
which I know you're going
to talk about as well.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, a
little demo there.
PAUL KINLAN: Track Elements,
WebRTC--
have we got WebRTC today?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, yeah.
Hopefully.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, we've got
a little bit of WebRTC.
Hopefully, we'll show you
something really cool.
SAM DUTTON: If the connectivity
gods are with us.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I've
seen a really good
demo out today, actually.
So if that all works, we're
going to have something really
cool to show.
But yeah, without much further
ado, I'll pass
you across to Sam.
And Sam will tell you all
the awesome things
about media and mobile.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
So I'm going to show
you some stuff.
We've got a stack of new APIs
being implemented for mobile,
which is really great to see,
because it's a kind of natural
home for video, I think.
You know, people using devices
when they're out and about.
And being able to enjoy video
from their phones and their
tablets and so on.
So straight up, I just wanted
to get us into a little
demonstration of something
that's new
for Chrome for Android.
And I think actually for
Firefox, for mobile as well--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
SAM DUTTON: which is great.
Which is Get User Media.
We've got the WebRTC APIs coming
into mobile for Firefox
and for Android Chrome.
And that means getUserMedia, RTC
peer connection-- that's
the thing for communicating
audio and video.
And the other one, which is
RTC Data Channel, which is
like WebSockets but
peer-to-peer, between
browsers, really fast.
Arbitary data communication.
Anyway, so just diving in, I
wanted to show you the state
of getUserMedia on mobile.
If we have a look at the Nexus
we've got here, you can see
we've got that running this
really simple getUserMedia
demo which is at
simple.info/gum.
And then if we look at the code
for that on the desktop
machine, I just wanted to show
you how damn simple it is now.
We've got a bit of faff at the
top there with navigating
getUserMedia.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh,
another camera.
That's the actual camera
pointing up at the--
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
that's right.
PAUL KINLAN: [INAUDIBLE].
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, it's
a bit weird.
Don't put my hand over it.
You can kind of see
what's going on.
Now we've got to get
getUserMedia.
We've got some stuff in there
to cope with the different
implementations.
And then you'll see below
that, we've got
a constraint object.
I'll talk a bit more
about that later.
And then when--
if we go down the code here,
you'll see when the
getUserMedia call is made, we
pass at the constraints, a
success call back and
an error call back.
And the success callback
is right there.
And I've actually put
this example--
the stream object so you can
access it from the console.
That's why that line's
in there.
But really, everything is done
here in that line video.src,
window.URL.creat
eObjectURL(localMediaStream).
That's it.
And that's setting the
source of the video--
works on mobile devices and it
works on Firefox, Opera--
PAUL KINLAN: So which
version of Chrome
is that at the moment?
Is that the beta channel?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, no, this
is working in stable.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, getUserMedia,
wow.
SAM DUTTON: I'm sorry,
on mobile.
It's in beta.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, I agree.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
On desktop, it's in stable and
likewise, yeah, we're seeing
that in Firefox.
PAUL KINLAN: You know I've
got a little question.
I don't know whether
this is a--
SAM DUTTON: Try me.
PAUL KINLAN: So I've always
wondered about getUserMedia.
It seems to start the actual
session off to actually get
the video camera
and everything.
How do you end it?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Yeah, well, you can
stop the stream.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, so this
local stream--
local media stream--
SAM DUTTON: That's right.
PAUL KINLAN: --you
got there is a--
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Let's see if it works.
It might work.
So I've got stream--
if we have a look actually, I
don't know if we can see that.
But I've put the-- like I said,
the stream variable in
global scope.
And yeah, we should, I think,
be able to stop that.
Let's try that.
Let's see if that worked.
Yes, it did.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh wow.
Awesome.
SAM DUTTON: See, I'm moving my
hand over the camera and
nothing's happening, because
I've stopped it.
And, yeah, that's it.
PAUL KINLAN: Sweet.
SAM DUTTON: So that's
how you can stop
the camera from recording.
PAUL KINLAN: Ah, nice.
SAM DUTTON: I've got a simple
way of doing it.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I've always
wondered about that one,
because I was like oh my god,
it's got access to the camera
all the time.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
So, look, I'll just demonstrate,
actually, just to
show what it looks like on the
device in terms of the
permissions, because this
is really important.
We need to make absolutely sure
that people know when
they're recording stuff.
So we've got the bar at the
top there with allow/deny.
And there is, I'd say, no way
you can do that without having
explicitly--
PAUL KINLAN: One of the
questions that Remy Sharp had
the other day was can you
select the camera?
I know it doesn't make much
difference on the Nexus 7,
because you only have a
front-facing camera.
SAM DUTTON: Now that's
interesting.
So that brings me to my next
topic, which is strengths.
PAUL KINLAN: Nice segue.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, I like it.
PAUL KINLAN: It's as
if we planned it.
SAM DUTTON: It's kind
of like that.
Yeah.
So, in fact, if we go to this
very similar looking demo on
the device, this is exactly
like the previous demo.
But if we get into the code
for this in the DevTools--
PAUL KINLAN: Just so everyone
knows at the moment, you have
actually connected DevTools
up to the mobile device.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, yeah.
So I'm taking that
through actually.
PAUL KINLAN: No, that's good.
It's one of those things that
we're trying to push quite a
lot at the moment.
There's a command called ADB,
and you can basically forward
all the requests from the
Android developer took kit at
the moment to the
mobile device.
And that's how you've got this
DevTools [INAUDIBLE].
SAM DUTTON: That's right.
PAUL KINLAN: It's not any
special kit or rig.
It's literally just a USB cable
straight to the device.
SAM DUTTON: Yep.
Got the USB plugged
in there, and then
just run the ADB command.
And yeah, it goes.
And then on the desktop machine,
local host, 9222, and
we get the full suite
of DevTools.
Fantastic.
Yeah, if we look through, you
can see the elements we got
here on the page.
We've got video there,
and so on and so on.
But if we go back to the
sources, you can see this is
really kind of the same
as the previous one.
But we have this constraints
object which now has some
mandatory rules.
And what I've said here is
that the max width of the
video that we're going to take
for the stream is 360.
That means 360 pixels.
Now the thing is that if we look
at the elements here--
let's look at that
video element.
Look at the metrics for that.
What you'll see is that
we've actually got
the size there at--
it's giving actually the size
of the video itself.
But what happens is that the
sizes that videos can be in
terms of their resolution
are actually
constrained to a fixed set.
At the moment, we
have no scaling,
and we have no cropping.
So essentially--
PAUL KINLAN: What's that mean?
SAM DUTTON: What that means is
that if you set the max width
of the video that you get from
the stream to be 360, that
doesn't mean that it will
take it to 360.
It will drop it to a fixed
set of sizes--
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, so it could
make it 240 width.
SAM DUTTON: --less that that.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, I got you.
SAM DUTTON: And we'll give
the links later.
But there's essentially a
fixed set of constraints
resolution sizes.
So dimensions x and
y dimensions
for the video stream.
PAUL KINLAN: So what other type
of mandatory options are
there on this?
SAM DUTTON: So we can specify
the width and height of the
stream which is implemented
now in Chrome.
And also planned is
the implementation
for the frame rates.
So you could specify that you
want a particular frame rate--
slow or whatever.
And yeah, to get back to your
question, we're also going to
be able to specify the front
and back cameras there.
So that's where that
will live.
That hasn't been implemented
yet.
And this is pretty
new stuff, so the
standards is still in flux.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, so it's
actually going to be a
programmatic thing, rather
than a user option.
SAM DUTTON: Yes.
So there's two things
that go on.
You can specify which cameras
you want to use.
And then when you select the
device from Allow, you can
select which camera you want
to use from there as well.
PAUL KINLAN: Right, OK, cool.
So if you wanted to do, like,
a flip of the camera, like
between front facing and the
back facing, you would
essentially stop the stream and
then redo getUserMedia but
with the front-facing camera
as one of the options.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, that's a
good question actually.
You would have to do
that at this point.
I can see that you might want to
be able to do that without
re-initiating the
whole process.
It is tricky because of course
there's this issue of privacy
that you don't want to be able
to flip between cameras
without the user giving
permission for that.
PAUL KINLAN: I got you.
Understood.
So does this apply for
audio as well?
I know that--
and we're not really touching
on audio today.
But are there constraints
for audio as well?
SAM DUTTON: Yes, there are.
Yeah, I haven't seen those
implemented yet.
But yeah, there should be some
constraints about the kind of
audio you can get in there, just
as there is for video.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, well, cool.
Because I remember when this was
first done, this API, and
the original constraints were
a string of audio-comma
[INAUDIBLE].
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, yeah,
that's right.
PAUL KINLAN: And it's like audio
true, audio, false or
video false or whatever it is.
SAM DUTTON: So audio lives
in here, like, you can--
I've just got a video here.
But if I put in audio there as
well, we can get the audio
from the microphone as well.
PAUL KINLAN: Can you-- are there
optional constraints--
think of optional constraints?
SAM DUTTON: Yes, that's right.
So there's various degrees.
I'm not even sure whether I can
remember on the standard
now what they are, but
there are optional
constraints and mandatory.
So depending on what's available
on the device.
Whether you would
like to specify
frame rate or whatever.
Or whether you are saying
don't let us
work if it's not available.
And one thing, just while I
remember to think about with
these constraints is that you
get a rather unintuitive error
message if you get them wrong.
It's just kind of "permission
denied." So, yeah, if you're
messing around with constraints,
you get something
like that, just bear
that in mind.
Because that can be
quite perplexing.
PAUL KINLAN: So the--
I've forgotten what the
next question was now.
SAM DUTTON: All right
then now.
PAUL KINLAN: I know.
Should we just make up
a question poll?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, go on.
PAUL KINLAN: Paula, producer,
do you have
a question as well?
No?
SAM DUTTON: No, you
saw it, yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Actually,
I know what it was.
It wasn't even a question.
It was these demos that you
have, we have a link
to them, don't we?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, we do.
PAUL KINLAN: We're going to pop
that up on the screen in a
couple of seconds.
Yeah, so if anyone wants to
try these out. you can
definitely try them out
with Android Chrome.
SAM DUTTON: That's
right, yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Beta
at the moment.
You could try them
out on probably
Firefox Android as well.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, let's--
PAUL KINLAN: I'm not sure
about Opera just yet.
But they'll also work on
the desktop as well.
So we've got pretty good support
for getUserMedia
across a variety of
the browsers.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, actually,
while we're there, I'll just
show you on the device.
The flag needs to be
set for WebRTC.
And if you go to Chrome/flag--
like about hyphen flags--
and you can do Find on page is
really the easiest way to find
the WebRTC.
PAUL KINLAN: But getUserMedia
hidden behind
that flag we well--
SAM DUTTON: That's right.
PAUL KINLAN: Not a
separate flag.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, and
then you enable--
you can see it.
It's enabled there, yes.
So that needs to be done in
order to use these demos.
By the way, while we're there,
don't forget the really handy
Chrome URLs page if you
forget any of these.
It's a really useful spot to--
PAUL KINLAN: So what
are Chrome URLs do?
SAM DUTTON: So
chrome://chrome-urls gives you
a full list of all the
Chrome URLs like--
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, there's
one called WebRTC.
SAM DUTTON: --sys
internals and--
actually I noticed the WebRTC
one isn't there at the moment.
PAUL KINLAN: What does
WebRTC internals do.
SAM DUTTON: I'll show
that later actually.
That shows you what's going
on with the current WebRTC
sessions, which is
really nice.
PAUL KINLAN: So that's
getUserMedia.
It's still pretty new.
And we got quite a lot
to talk about today.
So I think we should probably
jump onto the next topic.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, let's
move on a bit.
PAUL KINLAN: It's the track
element, right?
SAM DUTTON: That's right.
PAUL KINLAN: So do you want to
explain to everything what the
track element is?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
If we look at the track-- maybe
if I just demo this, I
think it might be the
simplest way.
So the track element was
designed as a way of getting
captions and subtitles
and stuff like timed
metadata into video.
So if we play this video, as you
can see I'm getting-- it's
a little bit hard to see on the
camera-- but you can see
that I've actually used the cue
change event to get the
value of each cue at
the bottom there.
If we actually go to the desktop
device-- hang on, I'll
just show you what
we're looking at.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The web is always changing,
and the way we
access it is changing.
The source of that
change, is you.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SAM DUTTON: I'll turn
off the sound.
I think that's all right,
just about.
I can take it up a little
bit bigger actually.
So what you can see there is
that in the video element,
I've got this track
element here.
And that points to what's called
a VTT file, which in
this case is like a
subtitles file.
If we go to that, you could
see it's a very
straightforward format.
We got these things
called cues.
Each one of these is a cue.
And it has timing and some
kind of hints to help the
thing may be displayed, and then
in this case some text.
Now the cool thing is that
this has just being
implemented on Chrome
for Android.
So this is really important.
So it's a huge improvement
for accessibility.
And it's also great if you want
to distribute content to
people who are speaking
different languages but want
to watch your videos.
PAUL KINLAN: OK.
So at the moment, the way it
works now, is it overlays
something on the video.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
That's right.
PAUL KINLAN: But it doesn't
actually work on Android
properties.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, now the other
thing I was going to say
is there's a bug.
PAUL KINLAN: But you can get
programmatic control what
you've done there.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, exactly.
In fact, if we inspect the--
this is kind of interesting
because if we look at the page
on the desktop machine in the
DevTools, and--
I think we can see the--
let's see if I can--
PAUL KINLAN: Do we need to
put the elements or the--
SAM DUTTON: I was going
to try and look at
the elements there.
Thank you, Paul.
He's helping me!
Yes.
So I just wanted to show you
something while we're there.
So if we look at the video here,
I've turned on just to
show you in the DevTools you
could see down in the bottom
there, I've turned
on Shadow DOM.
And what that means is that
it's pretty cool.
I can see the stuff for the
actual tracks there.
So that's pretty neat.
So if I look at the document
fragment there and I burrow
down here and play a bit.
PAUL KINLAN: So what you do now
is you actually embed--
like dive in deep into the
actual video elements, and not
the html representation of it.
SAM DUTTON: That's right.
So if I look in there now, you
can actually see the content
of that cue there.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh wow.
SAM DUTTON: So that's
pretty neat.
PAUL KINLAN: This is actually
pretty nice.
SAM DUTTON: And then you can
fool around with that stuff.
PAUL KINLAN: So is the track
element supported across
browsers yet or is
it just Chrome?
SAM DUTTON: Ah, it's just in
Chrome, but we're hoping for
better support across
other browsers.
PAUL KINLAN: Are there any
shims available for the
developers?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, there are.
[INAUDIBLE]
I think, did one.
I'll put some some documentation
about that.
Yeah, it's also possible to--
you can get the time of the
video and then kind of
fake it by putting a
div across the element.
But it's not bad.
It's not bad.
By the way, you can also
access the cue
itself to style it.
If I go to the CSS for this
file, let's add a little--
let's add a little style--
hang on, while I type.
PAUL KINLAN: Looks
like [INAUDIBLE].
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Excellent
color red.
OK, cool.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, you
should be able to--
hang on, it's not going to show
it on the-- because the--
if we did it on this one--
PAUL KINLAN: Can you put one and
say can you bump the fun
size up on it?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, anyway, it
won't show it on the device
because it's not there.
But that's the pseudo-selector
that is colon-colon-cue.
And there will be some other
pseudo-selectors coming as well.
So you can style cues just as
any other piece of text, which
is really nice.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So I know that
you did another demo.
Have you go that available
to show?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, yeah.
I just wanted to-- while
we're talking about--
PAUL KINLAN: This one?
I like this demo.
SAM DUTTON: --track.
Yeah.
So there's couple of things
I've done here.
This is one I really liked.
A guy just going on to
the desktop machine.
This does work on the mobile
device, I have to say.
PAUL KINLAN: It's
not [INAUDIBLE].
SAM DUTTON: The video is like
350 gigs, whatever.
Anyway, it's huge.
And if we bumped this up,
what this guy did was
he took video cycle--
PAUL KINLAN: [INAUDIBLE].
SAM DUTTON: This guy took some
video cycling around the
Google campus of Mountain
View, California.
And he got GPS data
to interact.
And what we're seeing is that,
as he goes around, the little
man moves around the map.
And we're seeing a Street
View synchronized.
Now this is all done via the
cues, so what you can see if
you look down--
I'll just drop it down a bit
so that I can see it.
Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: I think we're
getting some audio from here.
[INAUDIBLE].
SAM DUTTON: Oh OK, so
people [INAUDIBLE]
That could be better.
Yes, that's working.
Sorry about the extraneous--
PAUL KINLAN: Our producer
in the background is--
SAM DUTTON: Groaning.
PAUL KINLAN: --very pleased.
SAM DUTTON: So this
is really cool.
We had like this track
of xml data, turn
that into Track Cues.
And then we can synchronize the
playback of the video with
the man moving around
the back.
So if we move the man, you
can see the video moves.
And as the video moves,
the man moves.
I really like this
because it was--
the track element wasn't
designed for this stuff.
I did a similar thing
here-- if we
just get back to normal--
I did a little video search
for all the Google Chrome
videos from developer stuff.
So, again, what I've done is
I've got all the Google Chrome
transcripts from DDLs and all
this Google Chrome events.
And there's dozens of them,
190 or something.
And it's searching through all
those and returning these
results for a query.
And then if I click on one of
them, you can see that it goes
directly to that cue.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PAUL KINLAN: Nice.
SAM DUTTON: So, a really great
tool for getting into like
deep navigation and
search in media.
And like I say, this
is now available
on Chrome for Android.
It's really powerful stuff.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
That's a very nice demo.
I'm trying to work out much
time we got left.
We haven't probably got
a huge amount of time.
So we did have a section
of video and best
practices with video.
Shall we skip over that and save
that for another episode.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
no, absolutely.
Yeah.
Yeah, we can do that.
PAUL KINLAN: Because basically
we want to do a weekly series
for performance, Mobile
Media, and a whole
lot of other things.
And there's a lot to talk about
around how to actually--
the best practices for the video
element and actually how
to deliver video.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: I think we can save
that for another episode.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, sure.
PAUL KINLAN: And we'll get on to
the really, really, really
sexy stuff, if it all works.
SAM DUTTON: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes?
Shall we do that.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So--
SAM DUTTON: Without
further ado.
SAM DUTTON: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: I'll tell you--
it's a better WebRTC demo.
Yeah, so the actual links to all
the demos that we've got
are going to be on that
documentation that we've got.
So you could actually go
and try these out.
They do work only on Chrome, if
you've enabled the flag for
the moment.
So I encourage everyone
to go out and test it.
It's not a production-ready
feature just
yet for mobile phones.
Hopefully soon.
Don't know when though.
I think it's the easiest
thing to say.
SAM DUTTON: Yep.
So, yeah, just demoing
on the device now.
We've got Data Channel running
just on one page there, which
is a nice little demo showing
Data Channel's working.
PAUL KINLAN: So what would
you use Data Channel for?
SAM DUTTON: Ah, so Data Channel
is great for really,
really low latency transfer
data between peers.
The point is you need the
messaging and all that stuff,
as per any connectivity.
You need to be able to connect
between the two devices.
Once that's set up, you're going
as directly as possible
between them which is neat.
So faster than WebSockets
is the point.
PAUL KINLAN: So that's actually
really interesting,
because two of the projects
I've worked on-- the Super
Sync Chrome, Super Sync Sports,
and [? Jamware ?]
Chrome, they've all of this user
interaction piece, where
basically the user will find
another user in a different
country and have a race or
they'll make a band and join
it together.
And you have to have
low latency
messaging between the peers.
And there can be up to five
peers in each game,
I think, at a time.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
that's great.
PAUL KINLAN: Now, they couldn't
use WebRTC because it
wasn't available at the time.
So they use WebSockets, where
they basically have a central
server which one client pings
the server and bounces it off
to the other participants.
Obviously, it's an extra hop of
latency, and you don't know
where the main servers are and
all this other stuff as well.
So I'm presuming that Data
Channel itself as an API will
be something that's really
quite powerful.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, absolutely.
And we haven't got
it here today.
But there's been
interoperability demonstrated
with Firefox, which
is fantastic.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, for
Data Channel?
SAM DUTTON: So in other words,
we're talking about full
WebRTC interop between Firefox
Mobile Desktop and Chrome
Mobile Desktop.
PAUL KINLAN: It's
pretty powerful.
SAM DUTTON: Really exciting.
There's a bunch of these new
libraries and apps coming
through, which is just
what we hoped for.
We got stuff like Peer.js,
easyRTC and so on.
And the easyRTC estimate is
something like 3 billion
WebRTC devices in the next--
about 2016, so huge, huge
potential there.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
going to be cool.
I think it's one of those
fundamental pieces of tech
that's available to the web that
literally changes the way
that we communicate
with people.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, I like the
way one of the WebRTC
engineers described to me.
He said with RTC Data Channel
you're up against the speed of
light problem now.
They're really hitting
the wall.
PAUL KINLAN: It seems like
a telecoms problem now.
Does that make sense?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Exactly.
PAUL KINLAN: I always find the
API like a telecoms API, but
[INAUDIBLE]--
like you're getting these APIs
built on top of it now.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, no, no, we
got these great libraries
coming through.
If people want to look, check
out the links, and you'll see
that we've got these libraries
like easyRTC, like full stack
for the back-end, the front-end,
messaging,
everything in there.
So you don't have to-- yeah,
the API can be--
it's a lot of work to get your
head around the whole deal
with messaging, peer
connections, turn service,
[INAUDIBLE] service and so on.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So should we do the-- can we
show the demo that we were
going to show?
SAM DUTTON: Ohhh,
come on then.
PAUL KINLAN: I know we haven't
got an amazing amount time,
and there's probably not
much point in showing a
lot of code for this.
But it's a pretty good
one, this one.
SAM DUTTON: OK.
So I wanted to use this app.
I don't even know
the name of it.
I think it's conversatio
or conversat.io.
Let's see if I can
it get to work.
So I'm going to this site,
converset.io/ok.
This it's all you have
to do to join
this video chat client.
You're allowed to--
PAUL KINLAN: I will just say
though to everyone we're not
actually streaming live.
SAM DUTTON: Wow!
It's done it.
PAUL KINLAN: How cool.
SAM DUTTON: That's great!
PAUL KINLAN: This
is really cool.
So I can see your hand moving
in front of the camera.
SAM DUTTON: I'll try
and get in there.
Hello Paul.
PAUL KINLAN: I saw
your glasses.
How cool.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
OK.
PAUL KINLAN: So you can't join
us now because we're actually
cheating a little bit,
and not filming
exactly live this week.
But if we were live, you
could get people
joining in quite easily.
Because you look at that URL,
use this extra service.
It's pretty nice.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
that's right.
PAUL KINLAN: Hello.
SAM DUTTON: Lovely, yeah.
I'm going to kill it off now.
PAUL KINLAN: That was actually
pretty quick.
SAM DUTTON: I know.
PAUL KINLAN: It's pretty cool.
SAM DUTTON: It's fantastic.
PAUL KINLAN: Well, did our
producer want to join into
this conversation?
SAM DUTTON: Slash ok.
PAUL KINLAN: We need to give
him some love at least.
SAM DUTTON: Is he there?
Is he coming through?
PAUL KINLAN: Aww, he's
got a sad face.
SAM DUTTON: Sad face.
PAUL KINLAN: Forward slash OK?
No?
He's motioning to us like
he's got something.
SAM DUTTON: He's getting
something.
Just while that's happening,
the other thing that we're
getting with these set
ups like easyRTC is
access to SIP gateways.
What that means is we can get
from the WebRTC, Web World to
the what's called the--
here he is!
PAUL KINLAN: Hello.
You can say hello as well.
PRODUCER: Hello.
SAM DUTTON: Tragically,
I can't see him here.
You can see him--
PAUL KINLAN: I can see
him on my desktop.
SAM DUTTON: Can we put that
one under the camera?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, we can put
that into the camera, I think.
SAM DUTTON: Come on.
PAUL KINLAN: Just to prove
that it's actually--
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
it is working.
PAUL KINLAN: Paul, give him
a couple seconds of fame.
I know you can't see very
well but there we are.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
The man behind the desk.
PAUL KINLAN: He's actually
gone off from him Nexus--
Galaxy Nexus S, is it? or
Galaxy Nexus phone?
I can't remember which
one it is, but--
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Wow, I can
hear my voice about
half a second later.
SAM DUTTON: That
is a bit weird.
I might have to kill
this, I think.
PAUL KINLAN: I cut off my own.
That's actually pretty
impressive.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
It's great.
PAUL KINLAN: That's the type of
thing that can be enabled
by this, right?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And once
it's on phones
and tablets and desktops?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: We've got a pretty
ubiquitous kind of
communication.
SAM DUTTON: This is exactly
what we hoped for, like
easyRTC has the full stack.
It's ready to go.
it's easy to use and just to
build that into your web apps.
Also Peer.js, I recommend
for Data Channel.
I won't show you the code
now, but it's really
straight-forward.
PAUL KINLAN: We can
go into that.
If people are interested, we can
do another episode around
Peer.js, building mobile apps
which are collaborative,
essentially.
SAM DUTTON: I mean the nice
thing about these places like
Peer.js is that they're offering
the full back-in
service to it.
So they're offering turn
service, turn service, and the
messaging hosting.
All you put in your code is a
couple of lines, give or take,
and who you want to communicate
with, and that's
it
PAUL KINLAN: I really like the
stuff that's happening now,
because I remember a couple
years ago we did this app
where you could dial a screen.
Like you'd ring up a phone
number and then
start talking to screen.
And it was a hack upon a hack.
It was like XMPP
in the back-end
talking to the screen.
We got like hosted voice XML
solution which would fire off
the request when you said
North and South.
It was pretty cool for the time,
but it was such a pain.
It was quite slow.
And if you can just dial
straight into a web page, via
a SIP gateway--
SAM DUTTON: Ohh, I know.
It's good.
PAUL KINLAN: I'm actually quite
kind of excited by this.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, yeah, that
whole thing, what's called
PSTN, which is like the normal
telephone network, completely
now interoperable with WebRTC
apps running on computers.
I mean, cool, fantastic.
PAUL KINLAN: So yes.
Thank you very much.
I think that ends our time.
I think we're run over
our allotted time.
We've actually got a
lot to talk about.
We did this with Jake's show
the other day, where we ran
quite a lot over.
We've got a lot of content
to tell you guys.
It's not all going to
be Chrome-based.
It's going to be best practices
for building mobile
media based applications.
So suppose without much
further of ado--
is that even a phrase?
SAM DUTTON: Further of ado?
PAUL KINLAN: Futher of ado?
Without much further
of something.
SAM DUTTON: Sounds good.
PAUL KINLAN: I think
we'll end it there.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
SAM DUTTON: I'm Sam Dutton.
And yeah, we'll be bringing
you lots more stuff about
using the video element on
mobile devices and all that.
PAUL KINLAN: And thank
you to Paul Lewis,
our producer today.
SAM DUTTON: Yes, good man.
PAUL KINLAN: So. thank
you very much, and
we'll see you soon.
SAM DUTTON: See you next time.
Bye.